all right let's hit on number two so
the second problem with getting involved
in a long-term basis with single moms
fellas
is you've got uh 100 responsibility
with zero percent authority what i mean
by that is
when the children her children
specifically
need something resource is your time to
fix something
cars broken tuition's due for college or
university or something like that
they're our children but when it comes
time to discipline them
or to enforce boundaries most guys often
find that they're
her children at that time and that's not
a great deal for guys because
you're basically used like an atm you're
used to facilitate her
um new world order the conditions that
she wants
her her children to live in to benefit
from specifically
so understand that if you do get
involved with a single mom not only one
are you being
cuck but number two for the most part
you're gonna end up having a hundred
percent responsibility with no authority
now
that's just the tip of the iceberg if
you're involved in the relationship
usually it doesn't end there usually it
lasts a little bit longer especially if
you're living in a way that the state
determines
uh would be considered a marriage
whether it's common law whatever it is
that it's going to be called where you
live in the world
but there's many many cases that i've
come across where guy gets involved with
a woman with children in tow
from prior relationship or relationships
in some cases sometimes it's many
kids from several different fathers and
you know
they're together for a few years and for
whatever reason things don't work out
she wants to bounce and ends the
relationship he may have during that
period of time paid off all of her debt
paid for tuition school things for her
kids
and he can be on the hook over the long
term
for child support for children that
aren't even his
i don't know if there is a greater
uh reason why you should consider
avoiding getting
deeply involved with single mothers than
that
but that alone make it like if the state
is going to make you
or hold you accountable and responsible
for children that you did not
father it's absolutely absurd to me
men knowing this there's no excuse once
you know this but
knowing this would continue to pursue a
long-term relationship with a single mom
now some guys will do it it's usually
because they either aren't aware of the
details one
or two it's low-hanging fruit and it's
an easy option for them right it's easy
to get into it
you